Nicolle in Idaho says Dave my husband
and I are completely new to the idea of
budgeting my question is does the every
dollar app replace the envelope system
we're paying on debts that are based
online and require card in order to pay
them would it be effective to use and
stick with the every dollar app sure
every dollar app is just your budget
plan instead of using paper and pencil
and writing down your income at the top
of the page and then spending every
dollar giving every dollar a name down
the page until every dollar is gone
income - outgo equals exactly zero
that's a zero based budget and that's
how a budget is supposed to work you
need to every single month give every
single dollar an assignment and then
make sure it goes and does its
assignment and nothing else and that's
what your game plan is that tightens it
up and then the methodology by which you
pay it whether it's with a debit card
that's fine
whether it's with it'll each X that's
fine and whether there's some some
categories a few categories you can use
the envelope system all the envelope
system is is where you say okay we're
going to spend I'll make up a number 600
bucks 800 bucks on food this month we're
gonna spend 800 bucks on food this month
we get paid two times so we're going to
put 400 bucks out of each check into the
grocery budget but instead of just
writing a check or using the debit card
at the grocery store what I'm going to
do is I'm going to use the power of cash
to do two things and one remind me that
I'm spending money and two when the
envelopes empty it tells me to quit
spending money and so I'm gonna put $400
cash in an envelope instead of writing a
check at the grocery store I'm already
check to myself cash it out put 400 cash
an envelope write food on that envelope
and then don't buy anything out that
envelope except food and then when you
go to the grocery store you use actual
money and if your total is more than
$400 you're going to put something back
it keeps you from going over the budget
the allocated amount
for that category if you had a clothing
envelope and you went clothing shopping
you could go clothing shopping without
any guilt because whatever you spend on
clothing out of the clothing envelope is
okay as long as you'll spend more on
clothing then it's in the envelope
because there's not enough money that
are paid that register to pay the bill
when you go up and try to checkout right
so that's what the envelope system is
when you are actually handling cash it
activates the pain centers of the brain
you realize you are spending money
there's emotional friction involved and
it causes you to spend less and spend
more carefully but most of all the
purpose of the envelope system is to
keep you from going over in a couple of
categories the only thing you would use
the envelope system for are things you
don't do at home you pay a bill from
your computer sitting at home to pay
your light bill you don't use the
envelope system for that but if you're
buying clothing out walking around the
mall you're doing Christmas out walking
around the mall you got a Christmas
envelope right with cash in it and when
the Christmas envelope is empty go home
get out of the mall you're about to be
over served here yet financially
hungover time to move a different
direction if you're out of your home
spending money you can use the envelope
system and it will keep you on track
we're multimillionaires we still use the
envelope system for a few categories not
as many as we used to we used to have it
really dialed in and back in the day we
first started this stuff 30 years ago
every little thing had its own envelope
and we were just like fanatics about it
but that's how we got out of the mess
that's how we got it turned around
that's how we ended up with some money
because we didn't give it all away
stupid stores and we weren't constantly
busting the budget so the every dollar
app is the game plan you can have that
on your phone that says this is how much
I'm supposed to spend for a given
category you have that on your desktop
that's what I'm supposed to spend for a
given category I decided that this month
you decide what you want to do but then
the envelope system is just
cash for out walking around money and it
keeps you in line for those things